what's up bull podcast welcome to the
whirlpool podcast where we care about
what's our fools here just ready to go
round three go Toor right here that's at
each co-host of the year back to back
who told you that Johnny rocky right
here man just came fresh from ghanaians
Airport by his ex-girlfriend
we got Lisa Farrah Fawcett you know our
guest right here Francisco Ramos ruff
Rizzo we're gonna March it Rizzo he
could play my little brother like like
when I was out doing my movie I'm not
like that no more he was gonna play my
brother yeah really cool dude though
Apple boxes petroi me right yeah that's
fine in a second table
gee Papa was doing his big ass premiere
at the Staples Center and I [ __ ] it
was no sleep for Brooklyn for me rather
than where I was and he was a real
replacement I think really for what well
we were throwing out names yeah a good
one and it was 2009 he was about to lose
or eight yeah around there the good
money broke my red for four months I was
doing a taping our doodle-doo playing as
the house band on stage it was a big
deal yeah well at the time and then it
ended up going nowhere or getting
shelved but Felipe was late showing up
and everybody's freaking out and I
didn't know where he was
cuz we had had a fight because he was on
a good one and he disappeared and so I
texted him and I was like you know
you're gonna lose a lotta money here
you know we need money everything that
should I was like this is our rent for
the next couple months but did you make
it he made it somehow with he showed up
ready least about money when their money
is like when let's go know what I had
wine beer but I don't know if it was a
stress or somebody roofied me but I
passed out in that green room after one
beer and then I was thinking what if
those [ __ ] could be like roofied my
drinks so I wouldn't interfere Tony
Montana was there yeah I was there bro
have one of the names replacement she
could show though look like it wasn't
reducers like not selling it or not
doing it the story's changed for a case
of wide but homeboy wouldn't throne is
special and they're like now we're go
but his special first Showtime oh well
no no yeah what's the damn that that's
kind of the bone one that was crazy
because we did a like our our special
like our he hosted it yeah and then a
show ended and then he did a one-hour
special right after ours really the
classic still working it ass up man wow
we have rooms he got that [ __ ] all
together right with eg no GI some dude
with a lot of money bTW I forget it was
like nights it was that was nights of
comedy or something Knights of Columbus
not that God why do that we're not
looking to do with a t-shirt to women
it was too cuz I remember her for like
that's when I heard about you right no
but I remember her like the first time
when I I think I mean I meant like they
all kind of like Latino comics was when
you show up like mm and well that was I
mean I moved to enough 2006 but like
when they had that was like Madden
Comedy Festival thing you know that's
when I've just first started so I was
like the first year two years and I was
in LA right Brooke advice good sleep I
don't have to write dog I'm just gonna
give you a notebook bro I'm out to talk
to look at Larry Omaha leaves yeah Wow
so Anna
are you gonna fight these guys man you
have any possible leads there he goes
leads yeah they kind of work it as ships
if I had a couple of more detectives man
yeah so you were at a festival no I was
I think I did like the new faces or
whatever you know something like that
but I was like but that was like the
first time that I started like I saw
like their you know your name you know
they did the big names that I from
London you know the lighting comedy
scene that when I first moved here I was
like oh cool here we prom dude bro were
you were you know well I was born in
Venezuela
but I moved to the US when I was 12 13
you don't even know rel and throw that
yeah right so crazy man I went I was
just there and I got it you do dear
brother I did they in prepare that Miami
improv but I thought of it as well as
crazy but that was pretty great so it's
I guess I can play there like there's
like oh yeah but I don't speak English I
was like well then you're not gonna
understand it I got in trouble there
when I was in Miami yeah what happened
catch a show cuz I put a tweet and that
I
I basically you know every rumor that I
got was like no there ain't no English
and they didn't know that where they
were going
build the wall man so I was like so my
joke was like hey man it's like this is
like basically like I'm a cousin or
uncle from Venezuela it's driving me
around you know like that's the tweet
you know comparing the uber driver to my
family [ __ ] the thing I don't know
somebody picked it up and put it in an
Instagram thing and then if they went
like fire like a semi right and people
are just going like hey [ __ ] you they
not a venezuelan they're like hey you
think you're like better than me cuz you
know like it's like you think you're
better than new bird drivers i was like
what the [ __ ] is like I was just
comparing one thing to the other is I'm
gonna switch to live dog how many
fathers you get
how many way followers you given that
sweet actually I got pretty much yeah
yeah no it was that better you know what
I mean it was like a good tweet because
it was like it was like 8020 you know I
mean eighty people like that twenty
people were just being like you know
like comments I guess that's not cool
man
but that's the thing with now like
everything that you put everybody Ariza
how they want to read it it was gonna
[ __ ] complain about anything it's like
a baby with like a candle like context
me I get manly I get like I took a
person or like a farm somebody pulls a
photo of me there's a bottle on his [ __ ]
and the person who posted the photo they
talk back like what the [ __ ] you put my
photo up but you're gonna back me up on
so much it okay put my photo hi Doug go
started vegan tacos
[Laughter]
yeah did you answer this fool ya see bro
what they run the [ __ ] man
anyway who rushed us out cuz I said I
have a gay cousin I said a joke oh man
that guy
you can't go really like the Diceman at
the MTV Music Awards in 91 but do you
answer back to people that come that's
what they want your [ __ ] I don't have
time brought to read a sad-ass Comics
comic did you do that comics you know
who did it or just sad you know and
they'd be gonna put up a new name
talking [ __ ] turning on your skin yeah
you know man I do my family but diarrhea
great the world's steak man are you a
guessing group text if I I don't I mean
a group talk to my family I think it's
on whatsapp or what what's up yeah yeah
I mean it's like and it's always like
they just I don't know like do they work
it's like it's always prayers prayers
and it's always at the end is like hey
send this to a hundred people are you
like Mexican food I like my second yeah
all of it like like tacos the three
paths ever happened I was [ __ ] high as
hell I got to the pocket chocolate room
before they closed and he had on top of
the grill he had leftover carne asada
chorizo bros out bird and say make me a
taco is that's great
you got your tear scripted are laugh bro
it was crazy bro and I don't like eating
skittles broke it off now
I pour lemon a little bit of salsa and
[ __ ] is what everything needs to be
they're wrong
just eat your brother's like our own
ever my girlfriend she's from North
Carolina it's like so
nice great
she hates the rainbow yeah but like we
went to like this tank Oakland casados
you know and like ya know the one in
like a Santa Monica but but I laid you
know she was like oh I was like do you
want to chyron day and the girl was
working she's like and she's like and
then we I had and she's like this is
pork rinds or like pork is like pork is
like he's like yeah it's like but it's
funny like it's like why does she know I
don't think she can handle they teach
Iran but she did she handles children is
20-piece of big is that together with
the skiers right
the wonder where you go when you go to
like in the night and supermarket and
they have their yeah that's like yeah
that's the one I got in there in my
victory Boulevard right there and I was
gonna but do you could buy us [ __ ] 64
hours stop be cool yeah little fun well
you want a drink you learn a nice range
whatever and they still have like an
aisle for like
Hispanic food I'm like go yeah I was
like what the whole supermarket is
Hispanic
it's like what do you still have an
aisle this is the real
there's a bodyguard to enter an aisle
imagine brother mains [ __ ] [ __ ] um
pull pull stuff out of Jeff scrape man
that would be better
I know you guys ever seen tamales in a
can don't [ __ ] it up
they're gonna know there is a little wax
paper yeah you deep-fry the microwave um
yeah like that - like into it she's
doing a vegan Frank's in a cat all bad
as if eating the Vienna sausage and
crackers well so who do know Spanish
comedy shows yeah yeah well I wanna I
mean I don't know we're gonna the next
one but that's the whole point is to
start doing it more and more just to get
more we did one other San Diego man
let's do the hour
Wow yeah that's great I'll scrape the
lower everybody's there like before from
Mexico and they have their own style and
then it's us just do it a Berg and stand
up in Spanish yeah yeah yeah but it's
like but I think that's the thing it's
like I think that's what I want yeah
like that's why I want to do a Spanish
American style I can stand up actually a
mix it we're doing the whole Spanish
show at The Comedy Store May 1660 we
haven't added the date we haven't added
it to the Comedy Store website yet we
have a boat we'll be there Luis Othello
from San Diego Tijuana Tijuana his home
oh the glasses of my order and I'm your
dad Jack roll
esta pasando me me gusta noir aquí
porque aquí no Tina screaming - man OH
exactly like apple juice sugar that
seems like a sad clown or something we
had a [ __ ] sold-out show right like
80 people and now but you know how
convenient schemata that show like Marty
Moreno there's a beacuse they came to
laugh that Bob's has to acknowledge
everybody this is my daddy I never seen
him in my life
bollocks bollocks
Instagram is peachy oh yeah I've heard
of him I never really seen the stuff
though I just saw because I know the guy
from like another he's I forget hit G B
D G or something like that or like he's
that another different name but like he
became but he became public as he was
doing that some show like in Estrella
Taveras kind of like America's Got
Talent
yeah and like they needed something like
a comic or something sheet and they're
like hey just put this mask on
crazy ed masks and then the guys like
I'm the companyís and he's just doing
crazy he's just saying like [ __ ]
Boonton i came in and i can in fact
that's what it's all bad boy puta
children are here they love work too but
by Osito eat Cheerios they're just
eating good
what's up boo okay man never get out of
the way is it man we need some people
show to Tacoma Washington man things are
light
I was just there I was in Tacoma just
say okay
no just the city just walked around
now some colleges come how many college
you do that we're like six in one week
cuz I had to do like the racial group
they're all like an hour away and they
were all from the state there are the
pages or different paychecks
no one different paychecks get whatever
you get like one for a whoa boy
yeah you got lucky dog like one time
when I was on though when I was there
the first year like I got a link it I
got some gigs so my price was too high
just a my pride was $2,500 for Pershore
mm-hmm these ten colleges try to
populate who are locally they belong
should I come in at $2,500 well Who am I
dealing Garcia it was like that block
booking of like let's just go like it
was different paycheck it makes it look
like it's more price I guess but I don't
too much too high for everybody yes and
I really nobody brought something that
people came for me always they say this
bad Josh Worf
yeah that's who ran a ticket rental
slips now it's hard doing this it's like
it's especially like the afterwards when
coming when you have to say hi I'll
compete next to a [ __ ] margarita
machine yeah yeah everybody that wants
to sell this [ __ ] yeah shows up to the
National Association of
College activities and the big batch
shake stars there brother I think has
got a big the flash shows up with
[ __ ] two million dollars yeah and he
goes you know what
I got [ __ ] $5,000 for the rain goes
to show a one-year this year I gotta
[ __ ] Johnny Rock let's go for a
thousand at the end of the year oh I'm
gonna get this whole carnival for 50
grand will get this job will show up I'm
look at this magician you know what I
love that [ __ ] little pony emotional
Pony I can rich Willy Wonka the hard
working people there are the karbix
basically because we shall bro it no
nothing with no [ __ ] up no eggs no
gimmicks bro no guitar chance or
whatever up shot we don't really have
our water bro we get there yeah then you
got [ __ ] bro who are scammers
bro oh yeah it's like you got pools like
what car salesman here goes it goes on a
lien my name is Jose Suarez a guy a
Chicano activist broad Chicano guy I'm
gonna say this Jakarta because it's what
I when that was doing a show a comedy
show luke tori everybody Donna and MIT
we're opposed to get paid well right but
you know man how the [ __ ] we get our no
child support and they found I used to
be there this is the check yeah [ __ ]
scammers so there was a guy there who
just a regular cholo who said that he
grew up in he goes through the streets
through the heroin addict but then he
graduated from college from the 20
program so that was your same brother
graduate from college and then he just
took he went up there bro like tweet a
hoax
Carlos sketch bro that he made up it was
whack ass punk dude super whack a Holmes
will you throw me
you take you up smarty orderly and he
start doing this whole monologue and
that was me 20 years ago Holmes okay
this guy fell off the wagon that weekend
oh that's a guy that was at MIT with you
guys the to college scam artist yeah he
was there he was
during a one-man show with us like he'll
do a one-man show during the day and
then our comedy still have started at
night so the students saw him first
talking to a little his little speech
about you know pretty much a speech that
anybody could do who who's had a
struggle who overcame anything you know
your became blood me but whatever those
people Latino organizations eat that
[ __ ] up oh yeah I love that because they
just want you to like it's everyday at
first and then you go to the colleges
and it's like nobody's there from the
club boy rappers who are rapping are
positive a positive of these ya know
whenever you have to file like I had to
fall a thing was like ID was like Spring
Break whatever is like Balu boom boom
and then you're like hey what's up guys
so everybody just [ __ ] went through a
hole watch off like adrenaline of like
ecstasy they're like alright and now
you're like hey everybody caught a free
t-shirt or they put you against and you
gotta follow somebody yeah poet that's
very like sad about like death I was
just talking say that brilliant guy was
a victimized into colleges and then I
alright that was fun everybody this guy
laughter you know we have first pressed
over here he said he lost the crawler
Thayne women's merit yeah PC there huh
oh yeah you have to get keep it like
very like very very Dell you know no
yeah but it was that no it's I mean it's
like [ __ ] I do it you know it's I got
a used to it now it's more of a thing
like and obviously pays well and I don't
know things and then you know you kind
of like work on material because it's
like the shows are hit or miss you know
literally it's like either one show like
you're doing like the last one I just
did I did in North Carolina it was like
okay for your background or Coke machine
now I try more and more of like a just
like a ho
for sure by itself full of milk that's
pretty much it no they put you in front
of our cafeteria and they're like hey
and you get a home in the wonder I know
it tests your your your soul boy if you
have a TV credit you know if you don't
have cheese if you have my TV credits
you're right but you know like when you
up there man like you want something you
know that's coming sadly you know
whatever man you watch a nice show
but now you're there a certain time
you're doing a chore 3:00 p.m.
like what am i doing I know certain
thing you was doing on one last show and
this one they introduce yours kind of
like all right you ready okay you guys
ready
I'm like no I'm like you got to go up
there I'm like oh Willy I have to like
you know it's like gives some credits at
least some people know yes bro oh hey
Tim lower the [ __ ] bottom dog Sarris
a sophomore he don't know what he's
doing we have an extension cord that
janitor coming all angry bro come back
with a [ __ ] station cord and you know
that was mumbling his probably you know
why cuz yet to roll that [ __ ]
he's rolling at a quality you know here
it is man because they don't you like he
for side for you now lights now I done I
there was one words like many have a mic
and I got there I'm like I'm not doing I
asked him I do voices but I talk about
what I'm not doing the show I don't know
they're like is that you want me to do a
my it's like the only thing that gives
the the actual of a show is your mind if
not I'm just a [ __ ] homeless guy I
did a show like that and the first the
QB with the committee were not before me
you pretend he had a microphone boy like
this the [ __ ] cashiers like where
they had you like it was a show and he
was like the old like everything was
going on at the same time so is the show
and then they have like people like
eating ice cream another person appear
seen another thing and I'm like so
you're and you're doing a show like that
and then a monkey came onstage a guide
there's an a monkey and I'm like and
then you're just gonna go with you can't
say [ __ ] you can say what the [ __ ] it is
you gotta go like here to addition to
hold a banana there's somebody got got
kinda brush to be a monkey
they edition they like you're not gonna
make it any comedy here didn't ever
happen to be looking right but Yuri had
at that fat shake that picks you up at
the college try to make out with you
yeah
as I said she's fat boys usually like
not even fat chicks I should be in
Slippery drill watching the god boy girl
from SNL addy something or maybe six it
was really short it was good but what is
it about it's about her going through
life and dating shitty guys and you know
being the fat girl at work and all this
stuff I'm like her boss is a dick it's
good it's based on a book
you're a far as college you've done you
say whatever I just man I did like they
went on on main I'm like fourth or
Fartman Farmington me he was and they
put me and you know also they put you in
the hotel it's always like [ __ ] it's
like for like this was like a [ __ ]
thing from like a horror movie it was
like they're like there was a lake in
there like one lady came in and I soon
as I got in I'm like you must be
Francisco I'm like a [ __ ] I get
killed like she who I was I'm like okay
yeah welcome to the end over here no
it's a it's I mean I've been it's like
and it's always it's always like you
land and you get a drive like two or
three hours to the to the little town
when there's no nothing there and then
you do the show and then you're gonna
wake up really early to go back to the
to take the next flight back it's like
and some people's like oh you visit a
lot I'm like no I you know Edina is like
you can't see and it's always little
towns it's not really a time to you like
really big satyrs weekend I did I see
the rapids never little very small town
okay yeah yeah a lot of Latinos were
that sure
yeah and I'm gonna know was driving some
guy raped me recognized me and up you
know in the [ __ ] freeway bro huh and
I was I turn I get that guy who drove a
key you know that person you know the
idea with phone number
well you want me to call him yeah call
him man I don't have any weed so that
the next day if I get up in the morning
if I did the show that night no I never
show up at a colony I do a show I never
been there the night before to do a
college I thought that they are so I'm
sure I must have shut up real early then
cuz I'm they showed me around town I
went to downtown and I remember I went
to the dom thrift store and I bought a a
projector an old movie projector and
about the movie the camera for it I were
super 8 super a camera and it works but
we never divide the camera but it for 59
bucks to queue with me you still have it
hell yeah is it work almost impossible
to find people to process that film
though there you go but I got Echo Park
there's gonna be some of our assistant
go cuz I do you know where have you ever
done the thing when they have to talk at
they were like hey when I go to dinner
after the show I'm like no I go dinner
because just is another show it's like
I'm not gonna do another show cuz now
cuz they saw you do it from one and now
you're like oh they're like you gotta be
on yeah you gotta be on again I'm like I
went to dad I think it why me again
yeah you know Washington that College
yeah they always take you to dinner
after that college like it's like I'm a
mandatory man Ariela
I remember I went and it was cold
dude it was cold and Chris read from
Kenneth BAE he was gonna show with us it
was someone and your way one of those
steel [ __ ] silk shirts we from
Philadelphia I guess that it's kind of
cold [ __ ] to him and then foo like no
like I want to like go back to my room
and get stoned you know it was no one
this house party clearly many more
photos trying to have them
really gonna have a chicken wing-eating
conscious right now so I'll just say
listen man have a hot week eating cotton
just to end it right Clete the hottest
cuz nobody could enjoy that and I
[ __ ] took a big bite
anyway I they dropped me off and Kenny
kid and I'm going with him still toward
the club cuz they're gonna have a party
for at the club everything a table and I
said I'm good I don't my show ready yeah
they're getting their money and we miss
the show total joke
[Laughter]
I'm gonna give you the check is our
email to your agent man that's another
thing too so I was like well we had a
trouble with the billing office and it
sounds like a [ __ ] does that sort of
thing that like after you do the the bad
show that when they get when they do
this you're like okay that was worth it
you know the one I'm like uh you know
they always get yeah you have to like ya
know I mean it's it's it is what it is
is like it was one it's like some the
other day is like well it could be it's
like either better you could be doing
something else like you know at least I
did yeah the hardest thing is getting to
that thanks to me exactly what you did
bro what and 2008 are working for a guy
and um he booked all the colleges
already yeah and he and I he gave me
$1,500 to go with him he flew me out and
he drove me with him and he turned he
undercut naca prices basically like yeah
he would he would do his own road oh
really
yes we were when we were in we were in
Chico State
anyway I'm still getting 1500 bucks
right for the whole or 17 but you're
still good a greeter part right but when
I got when I finish
show that that I was the main dude they
give me his check that fooled off man
blow it with like five g's really bye he
was charging five for a shell to put up
a show because he was deaf ear huh max
yeah so I was headlining dog Oh who's
the host oh he was a guy he was a show
run he wouldn't put the show together he
came in and undercut whatever the pay
was yeah yeah it's still math - that's a
lot so good though right yeah so I
agreed to go there for 1400 and then I
did the same thing in San Antonio about
there like seven colleges Wow three L's
lodges el oaks and did you ever have to
like the famous like do you have to be
clean or like Christian colleges where
you have to like come talk about like
further Christian College hallelujah
finish or I had to do was I did a show
and it pay really really well man it was
that though for for Walmart oh and I'm
Bentonville Arkansas where Walmart lives
bro I said where the kid became famous I
like yelling kid or where he lives
everybody was there dude but I was like
I did a show for the lot Peebles oh
those who are involved with all the
[ __ ] Walmart's yeah like the Bronx
Queen New Mexico Fresno you name it well
there's a lofty knows those who were
there yeah telling me about all the
tricks
yeah what tricks of our you know oh
brother tricks no okay one day you have
a daughter she's gonna find out about
that trick tricks for her two kids
you daughter find the dog man laying
somewhere Walmart floor and it says
please take me to the photo studio for a
reward and when you get to the photo
studio you get a reward and
con you into buying photos oh oh okay
okay all right I totally thought you're
going to need a teddy bear they always
need a teddy bear in the kids dressing
room to subliminal marketing oh really
I thought yeah I thought it was like you
were like and Walmart had a funny little
Danielle retail tips and Walmart has a
little dad's when they hire everybody
wouldn't have the corporate meetings and
they do those stupid ass pun yeah yeah
there's everybody do the ridiculous
really you know it right the Walmart
yeah similar liberal and I know the
chicken dance the McGarrigle quack quack
ah
for Walmart none I did first businesses
companies were do that yes chicken dance
[Laughter]
in our labor at the Comedy Store
improv that's not a common photographers
when I started that's when I started
working there I worked there for like
two years and then I you know from like
2000 yet so doesn't you know during the
Tommy days when it was like the star was
dead kind of thing and I worked there
got passed I stopped working there and
then you know if I should start doing
other shows around and stuff like that
but like comedy stores a birthday where
I became a comic I say you know where I
kept a regular yeah yeah my name is on
the wall next what's up we're after that
is a maggot duck next to a pipe
somewhere in the corner somewhere you
know but you'll find a pipe no no I
might if in front of the main room door
that's great yeah yeah I seen that one I
put it there myself well you can do that
it used to be in the front by Roseanne
Barr think I moved
no it's doing the main room you have to
I think Helen the main room of throat op
no there's one big one and then there's
another ones where the walls are I think
you have like - yes used to be in front
if I Roseanne Barr go then there's one
in the back did you move the
location yeah but I mean there's like -
what's up on the back when you're going
in through the hallways but I thought it
was moved because I sure did you uh did
you ever meet Mitzi yeah there I met her
when I showcasing it and I say hello to
her Freddy solo died at the funeral ah
she said she called me over
Godfather's car for spots call for spots
like in the funeral yeah that's very
mature that's difficult like you know
come around no more I would direct
remember I remember like it was dead and
we have a redneck we're having a
communist or Christmas party and Pauly
Shore has to ask people to come like
probably cuz I they were having a little
party I bet she bought a lot of food but
nobody was coming for the food and I'm
punished or asking all the comedian at
the org are you gonna come down there's
so much food for anybody
were you there poop yeah we were there
only us right meet you Rick Ramos all
right grandma
ducks on yeah he's like he was there
only rent I could begin to Ramos you
know when he was there but yeah he was
like what is he doing
is he still performing this will said he
was valiant cars no wait he's valonqar
yeah yeah it was like a teacher films
yeah Rick loves movies yeah your pockets
too right
yeah time with Nick and Johnny still
going on yeah it's surprising me too we
do it once a week pretty much like I
said last month how about the episode
already we're on like 87 or something
else yeah third you have water
episode 56 is folks yeah what's yours
yeah yeah man
yeah sorry for Georgia after George
before your podcast I do actually it's
called F and F podcasters with fabbrizio
Rachael and guy oh yeah now we're doing
like in English in Spanish so like we
both do like like same episode English
in Spanish oh so like we was short you
know we do it like one in Spanish and
one english but talking about kind of
like the same but it's not the same you
know but it's in English Spanish yeah
that's crazy man to those colleges yeah
it's too much I mean like I prefer to I
wish I could just do more something that
was really come up like man if I don't
know how the comedian I was dealing with
a hit man I'm gonna be here for one day
the professionals with nobody and it's
funny to like it's pretty good I only
saw the documentary about the comedian
in the road and I was here I saw
television and I'm in it to a lot of
community it's about bombing okay was it
called documentary Dyne laughs anyway
Kyra talks about that cuz you know the
role a - yeah then you know you don't
think about it right - somebody said
then she said yeah sometimes man like
the only people are talk to other people
that I checked they checked me into a
hotel room and the people that gave me a
ride to the show and that's it yeah no
no and it's funny it's like you can get
used to the learner who knows huh and
sometimes they just even go into the
college's just you're going in there and
like nobody says anything it's like
anybody can just walk in and I'm like I
go like what's the security in here like
literally like nobody says anything I
just walk came into the vein like
nothing and I'm like and I'm always feel
like a creep just driving around because
they always clone they never tell you
because I rent the cars and I'm there
like hey where can I park it's always
like oh you can parking lot eh
and I'm like I don't know so I'm driving
around man a guy you know just driving
around at night in a [ __ ] college
campus slow
guys like [ __ ] crazy now so it's like
that's the [ __ ] it's like it's so and
it's always like the whole thing is like
what's annoying is like Jones by
yourself like it'd be awesome if you can
bring people you know what I mean
because then you can have like it's
different but like it's cool when you
meet when like isn't when you have other
comics in the show and it's a different
shape how long you been a Willie Barcena
sparring partner
wait this is are you thinking I'm Nick
yeah you know just figure everybody's
been through no you know I never well I
never seen him I know I saw him I mean
most of the haha stuff like that I'm
more like you know I was seen you out of
the corner of his eye no I was being
kind of like what are you you know I
never like did anything to you know I've
heard the stories I was gonna like kept
myself kind of like far and be like but
uh but yeah no never
I heard of it started so I'm like you
know what I'm not gonna I never like hey
that's my joke I'm like rub your bottle
is like Judea that's my joke you go bro
we opened up with big comics Sebastian
Cetina
wack Albert school's out Albert's cool
man cool tour with him who iguanas - oh
really mr. Bastian bak I'm out of here
dog what do you mean you're out of here
in high school that's a porn good
encierro hockey here play the most money
any spanish latin super accurate yeah
for that for that water cycle you know
why cuz he brought in the American
audience
you know his actual name was Sebastian
[Laughter]
virtually last name but they were you
rookie
it's rocky right you change your name to
it slow kiddo you never change right did
you ever thought about changing because
I thought about him and I was like why
there's like it's not like I'm not
foolish Ricky Ricardo red heart but I
never said I thought I was like make
sure I be frank Rama
Frankie Rama Frankie Rama's but then she
thought I'm nobody I mean I have to like
now wear a hat
you know I like writing like a horse or
something I don't know I just have to be
like it was a burghers daughter here
Culiacan over here I also opened for
Steve now so does everybody else on TV
what I also did the firt open for Steve
in the beginning too he took me one a
couple of times like him and Sebastian
where basically they two people that I
can oh when I first did my first row of
spots you know well that I would most
Ravine you it was good it was fun you
know
little Texas and now we are know I was
mostly like shows like around like I had
them one that I remember the most was
the ticket there was I call that scene
onthe camula they make you look so
chunga Changa that chocolate Temecula
and then that other have you those have
you seen have you done that show Colin
inside it's like the ranch ranch that's
the difference the short Netflix right
right no no no no it's actually cool
yeah it's like it's like a three-hour
thing where do they give you a steak
Rachel there Nona Valley yeah yeah you
all right
the ranch it's yeah it's like three
hours of hotels right yes like a big
thing and like there's no second
it's like Allen military town something
I'm like yeah yeah yeah or you have to
pioneer town life like this is one of
the first ones that I have headlined the
first time it was like three hours and
they pay you like a hundred bucks and
I'm like okay I was like you really
drive and they're like a hundred bucks
on a steak fries a stake and you're like
I'm more I'm more fascinated about the
state than 100 I big books whatever
their food they had
they have Wagga burrito they go in there
you wanted a scraper you wanna roll open
a scrape restaurant it's all just who's
dull for a script restaurant like
Chipotle but people just line up and you
see it scrapes of stuff you know just
great what about of me bottoms this will
say an area on the grandes latina and
appeals to everyone she's like she's
Italian but she looks latina though
that's just cause she can't I mean but
she's supposed to be telling you I
always marketers nineteen all the time
Arianna God where the money is [ __ ]
as pop music Bobby Lee from the airport
now what happens another bucket but
people aren't here dog no more Gonzales
heating the pipe now it might be
following the story yeah yeah no I mean
I don't know absolute you know you know
eternal story bro he only worked at one
time I wasn't yeah well it's always
Steve I was in Texas enough how toys do
Gervinho
with our boots I don't know I don't know
he's gone I think about rights a little
taller him and see you he gave me a
piggyback
he's strong Texican he's five now he's
like my height maybe a little smaller
you five nine five four
how tall are you Johnny 5 8 Wow
it's five six one six five shout out to
water burger I don't know what's up boo
so what TV quiz you've been on or TV
show so I've been on uber so the Steve
version which one oh that one oh no
sister aunt Rijo
you know he was there lady dynamite I've
been on there I've been on shameless
I've been on there was the other one
that I've been oh no I forgot now oh I
also been Hanabi in this new one called
gente fide only so you play a kook when
you take Wednesday I take tomorrow to
attack I'm the under fail Felix Felix
I'm there like in Nicaragua no wonder
and cook I love my by somebody close to
their gettable I went into it bro every
I wouldn't it's a little bit closing I
would you know put my clothes and
everything they had I was already
worried perfect what yep yeah [ __ ] your
bookies dogs real ones
that's what never would you wish Rhodri
was sweats
ugly ass booty bro so I might say Joe
karate I went into that just came in
from the fitting big lady lady yeah yeah
some big ladies all loud noise for this
man's words I was talking to a big lady
and any federal or why she told her that
much to say here the plantar fasciitis
as you can oh my god was hurt what that
was surprising her that you
that you were had plans that he had
Birkenstocks on they was being roll with
a bit of pain she said yeah I had
plantar fasciitis I use a soul huh what
how'd you get it just high heels were
these crossdress my shoes were too big
yeah so we walk a guy he'll you
introduce someone I think must have been
tennis for me
say you like Serena Williams [ __ ] no but
I beat people
racquetball badminton Campbell Babbitt
Tamara
lacrosse I used to play baseball like it
was like a form of base back in
Venezuela we would do we use a tennis
ball and we just had to like and it was
we played was like baseball boarding
with the basketball court so in order to
you it had to hit the ball like this and
hit it on
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was they could just get the ride
going because they were on a schedule
you know so they sent them out to the
hallway we're standing there and
he's pulling it down and it won't go but
it's not cause he's fat
really it's because of the height of his
shoulders my heart is what it was like
it was weird and I was like what you
were on it like anyway then they showed
us the door that's man that's funny one
thing happened to me back in when me and
my sister were like my parents left us
in this theme park and back in Venezuela
and they're like they were like in the
roller-coaster and we're like only this
and then suddenly got stopped and then
we hear like from the in the whole
[ __ ] theme park los hermanos Ramos
put five INL entrada my parents were
[ __ ] con and we're like oh my god the
rive and they stopped the ride and we
had to like get done of the ride cuz I
was like my parents were calling us
because they were they went to pick us
up and I was like what the like you know
when you're like here you like embarrass
you I mean actually I was I went to
Disneyland like a couple like a year and
a half ago or something and my first
time I did it where I had an edible and
it was a much better it was fun like I
like I'm not a big weed guy but like my
face Mountain would be this that's what
that's what I did it was awesome I was
like you know you're like [ __ ] like
they would there was a cold wind take
any heart bro you don't know like I
wouldn't touch the edibles are hitting
me man I don't like really hot I start
feeling it sucks when you like someone
tells me they're after a little kids
food it sucks s he doesn't you never
never stops it's like it just keeps
going like on us on you're like Jeremiah
Delgado was so full a bit angel well we
said angel my brother that package and
that package came back
two month later so I don't have to took
three months to get back where the angel
Synod why is your name Jeremiah yeah
where can people follow you at I will
confirm in Twitter at Francisco Ramos or
Americans at Franciscan Ramos or in the
instagram at F Ramos comedy F Ramos
comedy
what's the craziest [ __ ] you see that
the Communists or we'll know with empty
hardly past on top of the piano
I've seen people you know the boys our
[ __ ] or you know that comics and you
see bro well I mean I don't like you
know who are there bro with Mike when we
have my young here yeah you're there we
talk about when Mike young and I growing
up on stage and blue him yes you were
there yeah yeah during the Joe Rogan I
met these know what no I wasn't there
when when he was there yeah yeah no I
was like I think I was I think I just
started coming in when the whole thing
happened with like Mencia and then he
was gone and then I never over vibe
after he left no that you happened [ __ ]
I mean I guess it was I mean I like well
when I started working there and like I
didn't I kind of like started learning
about everybody and the stuff I guess I
didn't know the history or anything like
that but it was it was pretty I mean
that [ __ ] wasn't it was like a whole
pretty like a boat like a ghost boat
that's like [ __ ] like going on and
like nobody [ __ ]
and nobody knows who's running in I mean
I literally when I started working there
like oh your work and they gave me a
shirt and I'm like all right why wasn't
a black one that like one and then like
what I do and I'm like I had to like ask
people what to do nobody told me what
you [ __ ] do it was like a complete
like you know and then when him whenever
you went up it was like nobody was there
everybody was just [ __ ] around doing
whatever
it was complete wasn't gonna blame s I
mean very cold 200 oh yeah everything it
was like selling right there in the in
the parking no dude will go make runs
bro who wants them yeah and it was money
enough we'll come back and give
everybody though so weak ass [ __ ] but it
was and it knows boys a party no the
house that everybody I'm up there yeah
yeah yeah yeah there's [ __ ] dougie
dougie boys yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
telling you I'm a little weak I never
done I think I'm too paranoid for that
[ __ ] now I think I'll do it up at the
house I'll tell you go there no because
it's like it was like I think when I was
working or hanging out there and they're
like there was actually happen and we
got what do they look like right there
that one dude that crazy eyes do it
looked like he looks like he like he'd
be like Bobcat go with but no buck I go
away they they the one has like crazy
like where's the green everyone was a
Mitchie would have Charlie Chaplin
hanging out outside and he she would
have let go
she where the Charlie Chaplin lady hang
on are walking around bro
for reals and then and then that guy
looked like like Bobcat go away that's
what I god I thought with the greens
yeah that do yeah yeah that grey he's oh
he still hangs out there yeah you know
he's never that guy Johnny something
they'll give comedians are jobs all
right yeah no I thought I remember that
guy but like I know that the green guy
still there he's like a [ __ ] he's
like he's like a schizophrenic guy just
goes around and all he why were right
yeah yeah yeah and he would do is just
be basically a Mondays he would just go
at the end and there's nobody there and
[ __ ] rant and then [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
no no robbery up a diet a guy who you
tell my Robert William Robert daya
it was up late at night a trance he was
like napkins in his hand like yeah yeah
yeah don't let that guy like I can make
no coconut
I don't know where he goes a bathroom he
had all the napkins yeah and he puts him
under his collar he's talking to Jenny
Williams
but his jokes are on point like they're
like topical jokes for right now exit
that is rambles yeah Trump is gonna
close the wall wah-wah you know but they
hear the punchline but I soaked the
person it's always clever but it's too
fast
yeah it's a really it's a witty like a
witty joke but they're just not too fast
back then I remember cuz like miss you
always had that dudes back the day he
dies you might have spots to go as he
passed was he he was always there like
on Mondays yeah he blows up yeah Robert
what daya what do you think it was about
his comedy that she liked was it just
the weird probably feel it was fresh and
Wow
and they hos do it to a bear they go
Robin Williams people [ __ ] with them was
it yeah yeah the basement bro and the
dice man we all looks like my
grandfather there was another guy who
was always like powerful right no it was
good with glasses he would just hope so
he was getting spots I ain't talked like
he was like but like back in the day he
was like very popular but like he [ __ ]
frisky you know Garcia he was like he
looked like like he had glasses like
curly her like old you know he was like
you were Godfrey no no no but he was
just like complete he goes very like I
think it was like back in the 8th he was
very popular but he was always so fun
joe flescher
he does the boys 4 of 9 i know for like
right he was like by apparently like he
was so [ __ ] up back in the day like i
know show up i tell it again you would
see the guy with a wood chipper that guy
that's Alan Stephen Stephen
but he would like apparently he would be
so [ __ ] up people would be like they
would be like they would steal their
spot you know be like Oh a spot people
be like oh you already went up he's like
oh you know he was that I thought it was
so like he was showed up to the [ __ ]
store and like I know you already went
up and then they were [ __ ] like cuz I
came back in the shed that was like
[ __ ] like I mean especially also
people would charge when I worked there
and everything like the people would
charge for the seats
you pay the seats and stuff like that so
like they made room like people would be
like I mean I did that too where you'd
be like if you want the VIP CD bro yeah
but apparently got crazy where people
were like I think when once somebody was
right very popper going up and they were
like charging like for 400 I will do
that one like Chappelle would go some
[ __ ] like that or was like people right
all right enough you're [ __ ] wrong
you guys aren't going nuts it's like you
know cuz they were like just open up the
prices to [ __ ] get anything you know
always done Danny gather with a fan who
turned into a show to essentially show
but it already sold out or no filling up
and I see me I'm sure he chose to get in
I see yes the mowing guy right there the
comedian and everything yeah that dude
you know that they got a friend of mine
real good man if you really want to go
to the show talk to him right now pay
him the money in cash
tell him you want to go see something my
friend so he went over there I fool was
like a baller and the one way of which
it took up and gave more to us someone
do it cut them in don't care these guys
these guys bro like when I come in and I
get up full or twenty bro yeah unless
these two fool their cars you know a tip
about like yolks not money what's up
well that general we know what I got two
more weeks left five hours a little
league day I wasn't there when that
happened he would do that dice man
yeah
I'll be in there for two hours saying
Aggie that's not right now honey that's
crazy
got the whole bug back of the net right
for our bro that's not what so he can
play a game or a gang he wheels pull
Rasheed he got mad at there they or I
saw something on Instagram he started
getting mad at a Sebastian because I
wish Sebastian bro be clear okay not
Albarn Maniscalco cuz apparently he was
like going like writing his Instagram
he's like you stole my essence you stole
my act
what yeah Oh dice but dude dice is Julia
and the Russian didn't answer backward
and then he is in class he did yeah
buddy but he was going oh not like dices
Jean I never sees the best to do a
[ __ ] nursery rhyme II yeah what's a
teen I have seen I'm gonna call him
Albarn next hello the only person I knew
Brian Holtzman back then I he looks
party made him really well the talking
statue broke you mean kick tomorrow
communist all right high kick the man
well I could tell me it was only one
Latino allowed I mean the comedian right
I part him for one night two nights
straight peanuts
PJ PJ he went to move to Vegas first and
I'm when I when I heard I was gonna my
Vegas I was like okay he's gonna die cuz
I thought I really thought he was gonna
like cuz every time he was
every night he was there [ __ ] just
funny you know would be hanging and
[ __ ] drinking and you could tell he
was [ __ ] oh I'm like it's like how do
you [ __ ] alive like every [ __ ] day
it's a life man I know I never come over
to kill me
but he was away move to Vegas i party
with him though Dave I can't believe Oh
foo that's because get up and go to work
on it really I'll go with you well party
with PJ I don't know what I came I don't
know what there was but I can't party
with PJ and then he said I have to work
I'll go with you so I went over there
all beat up
brother being dumped or when I beamed up
trying to be friend with everybody there
I still went home what's with house
afterwards to keep party waitwhat and
what do you work I didn't have no job
all right he worked the Comedy Store
door Oh call the comic star work and
there you're asking like what do i do
what's my role and there look probably
like this is just too good I know the
only job was literally to show up that's
it like if you show up on time that's it
I guess anything else you could like do
you have to do anything you put the name
on the work he I guess I remember I did
that when I was raining and I remember I
going like welding I hate those names
doing those names and I forget the names
but it was like that sock was I called
it you know doc yeah yeah he was holding
the vein like and is raining and I'm
like I'm like like I went to college
opposite boy who didn't go to college
man I'll be able to match it was a
college well there's me and Doc we look
at each other and just locked eyes was
truly working there back then
I know I mean I know he will hang out
but I he wasn't working at that time
when I was working there yeah I worked I
won't even work there like I mean I
started going there like two thousand
seven thousand eight and worked there
for like two years and they say it so
you still have family in balance with
Venezuela I have family with Venezuela
no yeah no I do yeah yeah
yeah everybody is everybody is I mean
the thin it's like it's funny it's like
I think when everything with Lion
cultures like Orion special in Venezuela
is that you grew up with like everything
always being so [ __ ] up you get used
to it
even though if it gets more [ __ ] up
it's like well you just have to keep
going and so like yeah everybody's
affected by you know like I have a buddy
of mine who's his he was talking to tell
me about his mom didn't have electricity
hasn't had electricity for a week you
know stuff like that so it's kind of
like so everybody's effect that I mean
right now luckily my family they're
doing fine you know with however
everything is you know but it's it's
completely you know [ __ ] up it's that
they were like you know you're waiting
to see what happens you know hopefully
the government you know gets [ __ ] up
bad you know the bad government and then
it comes in you know cause that's what
people understand the guy who's proclaim
himself president though right oh yeah
he's actually doing it in a legal way
you know people think he's just like no
no constitutionally it says like if he's
like let's say like the Speaker of the
House you know and it's like saying if
like if the go let's say Trump is a
legitimate one you know a legitimate you
know then he's not the president not the
vice president so now the Speaker of the
House yeah so that's what happened
because this guy's the only line for
yeah so and and he does anyone up he
wants to take they want they want these
people to leave and then he's gonna
become the president then he's gonna
have general elections and then people
can vote for whoever they want and he's
not gonna become present he I don't
think even well wrong you know but he's
just wants everybody to vote you know
those cuz that's a narco-state that's
what it is yeah those guys are protected
by the narcos you know by the old and
office Columbia or you know and Cubans
do their salad the Cuban government has
basically infiltrated the Venezuelan
government and they're there somebody
told me that I when I did my my Honda
Fit commercial the actor in my show the
commercial he was the national empire he
evidence well a to ära
he was the the boyfriend of the guy
Justin just that's you know boyfriend
being the first to see they he get he
beat him up too
allegedly
[Laughter]
we were doing a commercial he was
talking about that he you said that he
also said that the Cubans infiltrated
their videos were like years ago years
they have plans they have doctors
they're ready they're freaking I mean
the thing is like I believe that Vogon
Chavez when they started talking to
Fidel Castro if anything Castro told him
like a man you can do the same thing
that I've done here for 50 years because
I think the Venezuelan Cubans they have
that same kind of like type of
personality of a they're pacifists
they don't bring some people don't like
to create trouble they don't want to
fight they just want to party they just
want to have fun whatever so it's like
those are be easier people you can
control you know what I mean so you give
them something people don't whatever
like we do so I think that's what
happened now it's infiltrated into like
they're the ones who controlling ton and
like hey do this like this whole like
taking the electricity away and all that
[ __ ] that's a way to it's kind of like
abusive relationship like it's like if I
hit you all the time I go you know and
then also and I don't hate you it's like
well he didn't hit me today you know and
if that [ __ ] it's like well we finally
got electricity it's like now you're
supposed to [ __ ] have all the time
and who took do it just me the one who
took the lecture for you you know that
well it's not like then it's like that
because they stole all the money they
stole the stuff that [ __ ] plants
don't forget work and all the money that
should have stolen and there's also this
other - there's other rich [ __ ]
who are called Bali Chico's who are
these [ __ ] [ __ ] they're like four
five or six Venezuelan like guys I went
to college they went to [ __ ] they start
in the US and all this [ __ ] and they did
this business with the government to buy
plants for electricity for Venezuela but
they but they went to China they bought
cheap plants that don't work and they
[ __ ] let's say late pay them like a
billion like trillions of dollars they
got and they only pay like a hundred
million or whatever and they [ __ ]
stole that money on those Oh
[ __ ] are in [ __ ] Spain
they're all [ __ ] and those [ __ ]
basically again they livin it up livin
it up and they're just [ __ ] just
pieces of [ __ ] you know those guys are
cooking like I mean hopefully more
people are getting their names out so
[ __ ] nobody you know they can deport
them and you know
and from what you know are the people
with module or no no I I think it's all
[ __ ] oh it's all like when he puts
all his [ __ ] out it's like let's say
probably 10% people you know but 90% of
it was all propaganda solve all videos
it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] that they put up
it's like it's all [ __ ] and now what
they do is like they make you they pay
they're like do it or I'm gonna [ __ ]
fire you or do what I'm gonna arrest you
you know sounds like and they put a
little video of people here like
celebrating whatever now it's all
[ __ ] there nobody's there nobody not
even the people that I'm not saying
before back in when Chavez was and stuff
like that this he did have support of
course it did but now no nobody wants
them before you know they just you know
the whole point and and the thing is
like the only thing that that has them
in controls because they have the our
military the military that's it that's
the only way and once once but if they
and the thing is like everybody's
connected so it's like they can't
[ __ ] leave because if they leave they
will get arrested or they will not you
know what I mean so they have to kind of
like so either they go out you know oh
you know that's what I'm saying
hopefully somebody the u.s. comes in and
stuff like that and just you know it's
hard because you want like do you think
that would be a good thing for the u.s.
I mean have any messed up enough stuff I
know that's the thing it's like people
say that but I got and I saw have they
done in the Middle East was like at this
time was like yeah I want them to come
in and get rid of this [ __ ] I
know no but yeah but China is there yeah
of course I mean and I force that's
weird to me China that Russia is there
to the like are yeah they and to me
that's thing that's a scary part like
let's say it's too many places to me
that's a that's the way that I'm [ __ ]
war world war starts that's how Paul and
you know start you know what I mean like
it's like that's their the excuse for
everybody to feel somebody chicos money
tickets are the term describing the new
bourgeois are created by the Venezuelan
government of over Chavez and Chevys
more made up of a lot of people yeah who
became rich under the traveler
ministration the term was coined by
journalist who on Carlos a pata to
define the of oligarchy
there has developed under the protection
of the Chavez government corruption
abominable aggressor and Chavez
ministration sympathizer move billions
of dollars with the complexity of public
officials with some becoming rich under
the guise of socialism Henry Ramos you
later fool I know a leader of the
opposition party Democratic actually I
said corruption of the in the financial
industry and others sexual demands wala
is tied to government officials or the
chair ministration following the death
of Charlie the bully who si became more
powerful and held more influence or
Venezuela during the presidency of
Nicolas Maduro yeah so all the food he's
just a puppet he's just like my daughter
is a puppet on a fool or big-time money
guys huh yeah yeah they also say about
that other guy he's a puppet of the u.s.
now well I mean look [ __ ] I mean it's
good no I mean I to me it's like locusts
it's like obviously it's like the only
thing it's like what this guys doing
good is like he wants to get rid of this
guy's established what what was the
normal democracy where it is you know
I'm having and having [ __ ] you know
the thing is like what I understand is
like this [ __ ] I say that a no
where again we're doing all this [ __ ]
it's like the government the the country
is worse than when it was that's pretty
much that's the reality of it
he's like after 20 years is worse that's
it so it's like it's your fault doesn't
matter
yeah doesn't matter what your [ __ ]
like whatever like no it is worse so get
the [ __ ] out of there and let's go back
to work but nobody wants to give up our
another thing is ever they send the us
we're gonna kill people they're gonna
blow that's my that's what my yeah I
mean that's the thing you don't want
that you know we're not we're not we
don't have a lot of finesse when we go
into movie like that's that's the scary
part we're like guys like Dick Cheney
going like you're not going [ __ ] put a
bomb there you know and then again we'll
give it it you know they just want let's
get that oil right you know what I mean
I don't see it as a bunch of people live
here
it's like man that was a [ __ ] good
movie oh so Chaves then he really wasn't
about the Socialist ideal then huh I
thought he came in that way like he was
indigenous and I got people ya know he
was and I think I I think
I felt bad I think he had that idea and
he and that's why a lot of people voted
for it yeah and you know but I think
yeah like everything you know you get
corrupt by power and then other people
come in and started he came in through
the military as well oh no ya know he
was I was there he actually did a coup
to government I was there who Maduro no
no I was there it was in 89 I remember I
my was my apartment and my dad was like
we're putting the Christmas tree and all
of sudden we hear like bridging ya know
planes going like mom I mean why am i
deaf I can grab me and like it's like
get down you know like [ __ ] like Daddy
to do and that was like he was he that
was when a Chavez [ __ ] that you know
tried to didn't succeed and and it was
the saturate this video and you two were
like heat when he's getting interview
when he gets arrest he goes like a
comrades we we lost you know give up
your arms I you know but don't worry
I'll be back and he says I said and he
[ __ ] you know and the the stupid
thing is that this president actually
pardon him when he and then he and he
was allowed to [ __ ] run for president
and then he did all that [ __ ] and then
Castro did overthrew that's in jail let
me tell you let me tell you this guy
Chavez is like a [ __ ] big historical
leader the charisma was [ __ ] like not
like crazy like you could have gone like
[ __ ] Chavez [ __ ] Chavez you had lunch
with him and you're like yeah you know
and I bet like I bet Trump is like that
too I bet it's a stressful event like
that like I bet you like that and then
you have you hang with him and it's like
give you a couple of those huh yeah all
those guys have that [ __ ] Toby a blue
shirt I don't wear blue did you see he's
gonna give the medal of a freedom medal
freedom to a tiger was he just said
I'm gonna go get some hoes that's like
such a like a like can you be my frame
and play golf with me all right yeah
shows coming up ah man yeah I do have
actually have a Tampa I'm headlining the
Tampa improve worse Corona King Corona
they have go cigar whether I'm the good
you know I don't think I see gone
without good at coffee right there
really the Cuban coffee
really okay hold on I read a story I
think Allah follow Allah final on this
all cigars dude it's a old man I don't
know yeah well yeah they were food the
viagra's yeah chapel a chap no chapel
yeah they call it will topple the temple
I'm a bored City baby oh really
okay alright well may uh may second I'm
headlining the attempt I improve and
then I'm doing the awesome they tell
people man he called the Thank You
Jeremiah see you in Tampa good night
everybody now he's leaving would you a
mother's watering as I said yeah so yeah
please check that out I'll be fun if we
could find you at at Ephraim O's comedy
on Instagram Francisco Ramos Twitter and
Francisco e Ramos dot-com sorry Rocky
were you doing man I skipped town
tomorrow them with you in Tacoma May 14
people as jokes Riverside was so fully
vertical bite man we had an awesome show
up man much of Rizal killed this oh yeah
oh yeah I was like the man also a great
guy don't forget man April 24th
rather I'm doing a can of beans
last April foolishness show at the
microphone Microsoft Center April 26 Los
Angeles Albuquerque November actually
April 27 isleta Casino Lincoln
California May 4th at Thunder Valley
Casino Irvine California May 23rd to the
26 people nice were so full podcast
taking for the $2 well so cool thank you
for being a guest thanks for having me
Oh